joyless climate Crusaders have a new
enemy your four-legged friend
the media promoting a study that claims
our pets and their meat heavy diet are
part of the climate problem and suggests
it's time you feed your Pooch
insect-based food as a way to mitigate
their carbon paw prints the author of
the study also wants you to ditch Old
Yeller for pizza rat saying quote small
rodents and birds are great options
snakes turtles reptiles can have a
really low impact too for those that are
into it it's interesting uh Jesse did
you know when the idea of reducing the
carbon paw print came up do you know who
volunteered to lead the effort Barack
Obama that is correct
reducing emissions one Greyhound
well I mean so insulted
it's only what he admitted to the
passing of one joke is enough but four
or five
he's entered the picture yes
more of a repertoire by the way should
we just stop breeding large dogs Dana no
yeah
these are probably people who are also
say like you should be let's say eat
natural what do you think dogs ate
before they were domesticated yeah they
ate meat that's what they're going to
get and also they don't want you to have
a dog right but they will never give up
there yes exactly well nobody ever
nobody ever obeys their own orders judge
what do you make of this
come near my dogs you're in big trouble
I mean the whole idea that they would be
so arrogant so condescending to assume
that they should tell us whether or not
we should have a big dog what is it to
them who are these people where do they
come from
in charge why do we even talk about them
I don't know because it's fun and I get
to make jokes about Obama eating a dog
he admitted it six times but people need
to know he admitted it it's not a joke
you know Geraldo I did some research
about the insect diet did you know that
we already eat insects do you know that
like pills and candy and coffee beans
the waxy stuff around it is called
shellac which comes from the sack bug so
so the when you get jelly beans and like
Mike and Ice it's actually got the
exterior that's shellac that's shellac
it comes from the the sack bug where did
you find that out it's on Wikipedia
well all I know is my dog still eats dry
food uh as you'll see at the end of the
program he is enormous uh and when I do
try to sneak him a hamburger or steak he
gets the run so I'm I'm yeah I'm clear
I'm clear of this no there's nothing
worse than dog runs you know I'm
thinking anything what do you make of
the whole climate activism thing now
with people throwing stuff it seems to
me that they're using the climate as an
excuse to act out in public like it's
really about their narcissism that their
love starve they're looking for
attention because if you do something so
ridiculous no one's going to Cave to
that demand but they're enjoying the
moment of attention right and that's
what it's it's a performance yeah it is
it must be like a tick tock challenge or
something no I you think that this is
something that is to fill a hole in
their soul
I think that could be true but leave
them
I just leave them make them
all performance are turn out the heat
the lights go we're out of here just
leave them the whole time let them chant
till they can't chant anymore or we
could set him on fire Jesse oh my God
that's only when they squat okay gotcha
that's a joke America but eating dogs
that's no joke I'm gonna be on top of
that he did that's the seven fastest
seven fastest is up next I went on Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now